mein name ist lukas herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einer neuen folge ebay
fällt meine lieben freunde und ich würde
sagen wir fangen jetzt an mit diesem
fall hier ihr verkauft jemand gebrauchte
rollschuhe für 50 euro
darunter fällt man sich jetzt eventuell
sowas vor oder sowas
hier wird allerdings dass sie jetzt
schon gar keinen bock mehr das hier ist
das nächste produkt das auf ebay
verkauft wird und zwar ist es ein
aquarium gruß ja ich würde dir was
anderes empfehlen sprachenlernen als
nächstes verkauft hier jemand für 15
euro schuhe leder mit schweinen nase
größe 40 versand fünf euro oder abholung
oder denken sich jetzt eventuell hater
erlaubt ja dann spaß als fans schweins
nasen schuhe gibt na ja ich meine wer
feiert kommen wir allerdings nun zum
ersten chat fall ausfällt und zwar
schreibt ein interessent 15 und käme
sofort dann antwortet der verkäufer 15
euro sind mir zu wenig wir können uns
auf 25 euro einigen 20 und ein kuss ja
bruder da wäre ich ja direkt verwertete
double
das ist das nächste ebay angeboten der
aufmerksame kriechen kochen so soll man
sonst kochen holz in der küche luca oder
aufmerksame koch erkennt natürlich
direkt dass das eine friteuse ist der
user hat sich allerdings verschrieben
und verkauft ihr seiner ansicht nach
eine friseuse jahr zehn euro für eine
friseuse sehr entspannt hat gerade den
hund eingefangen er lief
mutterseelenallein hier bei uns in der
straße rum ohne halsband falls jemand
weiß wer diesen süßen fratz vermisst
bitte per private nachrichten melden
ansonsten bringe ich ihn ins tierheim
seine extrem süße nachricht erst dann
auch noch ein bild und angenehm bruder
das ist ein meerschweinchen weil die
fresse du laufen als nächstes verkauft
ein user dieses bild hier auf ebay und
schreibt in den titel geiles bild für
wohnungs zimmer mit rahmen für 1300 euro
die artist weiteres und in der
beschreibung steht gutes bild für
wohnungs zimmer rahmen kann nicht
geändert werden ist mit schrauben rein
geklebt ja degas werk ins nicht wenn man
für 3300 euro ein bild von einer
hässlichen katze verkauft und dann auch
noch sagt der rahmen kann ich geändert
werden weil die schrauben sind rein
geklebt ich klebe schrauben auch immer
das hier ist das nächste angebot und
zwar seht ihr schon dass es ein sack und
die person schreibt sagt zu verschenken
in klammern allerdings reserviert
der sack ist für mich zu eng und dunkel
nur an selbstabholer und es gibt keine
rücknahme ja das ist schon blöd wenn man
tot ist und dann liegt man im sack und
ist es auch noch zu dunkel und zu eng da
drin
ich meine man will ja eine aussicht
haben oder nicht als es ist verschenkt
er eine person auf ebay ein trampolin
und ich meine das ist halt ein negatives
angebot denn man müsste sich das
trampolin halt selbst abholen aber das
ist ja überhaupt kein problem also ich
hoffe er findet auf jeden fall
einkäufern ich bin zuversichtlich dass
er das tut
und der nächste ebay fälle handelt von
einem iphone 11 promax 256 gigabyte
verschweißt da ist man extrem langer
produktname allerdings fragt ein
interessent hallo gerät noch da
daraufhin antwortet der verkäufer ja
warum
nur so
oh mein gott das das erste mal dass ich
im heutigen video geklatscht habe ja
kann nicht sein dass die bisher erst
einmal geklatscht haben beim
nächstenliebe fällen haben wir mal
wieder einen kreativen raimund zwar ist
es ein vogel ist es ein flugzeug ist es
dein vater nein es ist ein süßer k der
das hier ist das nächste
wurde und zwar verkauft jemand für fünf
euro die maus die mit der sendung mit
der maus und das ist das wild und die
maus sieht so aus als wäre sie jahrelang
crack abhängig gewesen und ist gerade
auf entzug
dieses kissen hier meine lieben freunde
kommt am 21
februar um 15 uhr in lucka shop und zwar
nur 1000 mal also es wird streng
limitiert sein das habe ich schon mal
gelaunt schon jetzt kam mega gut bei
euch an
deswegen haben gesagt wir schieben noch
mal 1000 kitzen hinterher jede
bestellung bekommt eine von mir
handsignierte autogrammkarte also
schreibt euch den 25 5 ich weiß nicht
mal mein geburtstag ist der garten
machen wir nun allerdings direkt weiter
mit dem nächsten ebay fail und zwar
einem erneuten reime rosen sind rot
meine küche riecht gut und ist sauber
dank diesem wundervollen abdruck sauber
ja dir würde ich auch sprachen lernen
empfehlen dass jetzt das nächste produkt
das auf ebay verkauft wird und man
erkennt schon dass es einen wlan router
als von o2 die person schreibt
allerdings in den titel home box von o2
für 20 euro ja irgendwie kann ich bei
den ebay feld dauerhaft sprachenlernen
einblenden wollen wir nun allerdings zu
einem ebay fällen bei dem ich wirklich
erstaunt war ihn zu sehen und zwar ist
es das hier erst mal das war das anzeige
bild also eines von diesen limited
edition coca cola mcdonalds gläsern und
im drittel von der anzeige steht einfach
tanzverbot mcdonald's glas doppelpunkt
banker hat in diesem trick für 50 euro
ich weiß nicht ob ich da was verpasst
habe und ich weiß auch nicht ob ich das
[Musik]
aber das wurde mir auch extreme häufig
zu gewinnen und zwar verkauft da
wirklich eine person tanz tanz war wird
auf ebay allerdings nicht als tanzverbot
sondern einfach als ehrenmann hashtag
tanz ami also ich glaube das ist der
name von seiner community oder so also
scheint von einer seiner community
gemacht zu haben also ja falls jemand
von euch kann zwar wurde ab und will was
ein super seriöses angebot ist müsst ihr
nur 3000 euro bezahlen auch ein super
aktuelles bild hast da geführt worden
ist machen wir nun allerdings wieder
weiter mit einem chat verlauf mich wird
allgemein mehr interessieren findet ihr
chat verläufe lustiger oder so die
anzeigen mit bildern und so was alles so
stimmt gern mal hier oben ab das frage
ich mich halt immer weil wir werden so
viele fans zugesendet und ich bin
meistens nur die mit bildern also nicht
statt verläufe weil ich die selbst
lustig findet aber wenn ihr sagte chatt
verläufe sind mindestens genauso wird
sich dann nämlich mal mehr davon rein
fragt auf jeden fall ein interessent
noch zu haben
daraufhin antwortet der verkäufer ja
versand möglich liebe grüße ja auch das
25 inklusive versand 28 corman 25 ist
gerade zahl ja und an der stelle
wirklich wirklich einfach nur noch sagen
zu müssen dass das jetzt der nächste
ebay verkauft hat eine person herr thoma
für 50 euro verhandelbar ich bringe es
einfach nicht über das herz herr thoma
leid zuzufügen
er guckt einen so unschuldig an als ob
er alles verstehen würde ich bin ganz
ehrlich sind wirklich aus wie man mit
einer etwas langnase oder halt einfach
wieder extrem gehen wann die politik zu
tun hat wird der nächste ebay fail ist
gar kein richtiger fail im sinne von der
iss in trance rechtschreibfehler oder
her was verkauft der typ dafür ein
schwachsinn aber es ist einfach kreativ
und lustig dargestellt und zwar verkauft
dort eine person einen hut ohne ecken
steht dir gut im titel mit der
beschreibung steht schicker hut mütze
ohne hund dabei setzt hat den hut seinem
hund auf also warum kannst du ihn nicht
einfach normal vor dich hin legen so wie
jeder andere user auch ein mann
allerdings weiter wieder mit einem chat
verlaufen zwar schreibt ein
interessanter habt vielen dank für 50
euro nämlich die mit auch wenn ich sie
für 30 euro verkaufen möchte
sorry das ist mir zu viel das mir grad
gesagt du willst die für 50 euro haben
nicht frech werden ja
ich verstehe absolut nur bahnhof als
nächstes verkauft ihr jemand eine
porzellan katze und ein interessent
fragte guten tag ist diese katze
kastriert ich habe ein kater nämlich
vielen grüße ja wir kennen
wenn der kater dann plötzlich von einer
porzellan katze befruchtet wird biologie
war nicht so mein ding kommen allerdings
nur noch schon zum vorletzten ebay fällt
für die heute der episode und zwar
verkauft ihr jemand sein iphone hat
apple gerät und zubehör gerät allein
immer diese dummen kategorien jeder weiß
was ein scheiß iphone ist aber okay wir
machen weiter im programm der zustand
ist auf jeden fall gebraucht und in der
beschreibung schreibt er haye verkaufe
hier mein iphone 7 für 250 euro
allerdings gibt es nach dem kauf die
chance auf 150 euro geld zurück jetzt
hat mein wecker geklingelt und darauf
habe ich gefährlich willkommen auf einem
kanal da habe ich menschen nicht gesehen
aber gut nach weiter im programm und
zwar schreibt die person daraufhin
weiter ich bin leidenschaftlicher
fußballfan solltest du das handy bei mir
kaufen und werder bremen am samstag
gegen leverkusen gewinnen erhältst du
150 euro des kaufpreises direkt zurück
alles via paypal oder banküberweisung
wie du möchtest also eine art cashback
garantie auf deinem handy kauf etwas
ungewöhnlich aber man kann es ja mal
versuchen sollte leverkusen das spiel
gewinnen oder die partie unentschieden
aus dem bleibt trotzdem einem fairen
preis von 250 euro billig eine
interessante idee allerdings bremen
gerade extrem schlecht von einer
ganzheitlich direkt 250 euro schreiben
weil ich so meine lieben freunde zum
letzten ball fällt für die heutige folge
und verkauft jemand drei regale aus holz
und ein interessent fragt hallo sind die
regale noch zu haben
eine stunde später bekommt er die
antwort hallo ja das sind sie liebe
grüße zwei minuten später hallo ja das
sind sie liebe grüße zwei minuten später
hallo sind noch da liebe grüße sechs
minuten später hallo
sieben minuten später hallo ja das sind
sie liebe grüße 35 minuten später hallo
ja die regale sind noch da liebe grüße
an der stelle meine lieben freunde wird
das heutige video ist allerdings auch
beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch und dann wieder
ab und man kann einfach keine lücke sagt
wenn ich dann endlich gehen auf die
glocken schreibt immer gerne und in die
kommentare
ob ihr denkt dass die regale vielleicht
noch da sind muss man gut zu überlegen
[Musik]
na ja normal gerechnet